[Música]
a educação para mim é algo que sempre
fez parte da minha vida eu fui uma
adolescente uma jovem extremamente
questionadora
a escola pra mim nunca fez sentido
e ela nunca fez sentido porque nunca
ninguém parou para perguntar pra
entender o que eu queria aprender como
eu queria aprender quais eram os meus
sonhos meu projeto de vida era muito o
tópico tudo isso a escola tinha um único
tamanho pra todo mundo e quando eu virei
adulta eu resolvi então e para a área de
educação para ajudar que outros jovens
não passassem pelo mesmo que eu passei
e quando eu fui ser professora eu sempre
parei pra pensar para entender quem são
meus alunos
quem são esses alunos que estão comigo
hoje em sala de aula como eles pensam
quais são seus sonhos pra onde onde eles
querem estar daqui alguns anos
entendendo também com esse contexto que
eles viveram como será o mundo quando
eles forem adultos para pensar o melhor
que eu poderia fazer por eles então é
sobre isso que eu quero conversar com
vocês hoje porque como maurício bem
contou
nós estamos num momento muito especial
da história da humanidade um momento
novo
o momento que nós não temos ainda muita
noção para onde nós vamos
como vai ser o mundo daqui a uns anos
tudo está mudando muito rápido a
inteligência artificial está mudando a
forma como nós nos relacionamos a forma
como nos comunicamos uns com os outros
a forma como nós gerenciamos a nossa
vida e as oportunidades de
empregabilidade
então é sobre isso que nós precisamos
entender quem é professor aqui tem que
entender esse contexto para pensar qual
é a melhor estratégia de ensino que vai
poder organizar seus alunos
e quando eu penso então em planejar uma
aula
eu sempre vou entender quem é esse
público
com esse contexto de sociedade que ele
vai ter oportunidade de ver e qual esse
contexto de empregabilidade de
oportunidades de empregabilidade que ele
vai ter então entendendo primeiro um
pouco quem essa geração que está conosco
essa geração hoje é chamada de geração
millenium e ela tem características
muito diferentes das gerações anteriores
ela está o tempo todo conectado
algumas vezes nós dizemos que os
celulares são extensão do corpo dessas
pessoas
por conta disso elas são extremamente
colaborativa muito mais do que nós
pensamos
um aluno quando ele tem uma dificuldade
de aprendizagem quando ele precisa fazer
um trabalho ele rapidamente encontra
outros alunos no sua rede para poder
resolver esse problema ou para fazer
esse trabalho juntos eles usam as
tecnologias o skype eo google docs
qualquer tecnologia de uma forma muito
simples e nós nem a geração anterior que
nasceu com tudo isso à disposição muitas
vezes para ficar entendendo para que
serve cada uma delas
eles são extremamente imediatismo
imediatista
eles pensam no aqui e no agora eles não
têm muitas a ideia de futuro
eles não têm essa idéia de futuro porque
primeiro é muito difícil né gente
imaginar como vai ser esse futuro
até pouco tempo nós tínhamos há 15 20
profissões
quando você era criança você imaginava
que você a ser médico engenheiro
advogado professor netinha algumas
carreiras que você a seguir
hoje você entra numa universidade e
muitas vezes não consegue nem saber do
que se trata daquele curso
então é muito difícil a gente ter essa
visão de futuro
eles são também extremamente imediatista
porque eles estão o tempo todo nas redes
sociais é o registrando o aqui eo
agora eu não sei se vocês já tentaram
alguma vez fazer uma pesquisa no
facebook por exemplo e viram o quanto é
difícil você achar aquela informação
interessante que você viu muitas vezes
em que voltando à nossa linha do tempo
entrar na linha do tempo de um colega
para poder encontrar aquela informação e
não é porque o mark zuckenberg sua
equipe não fosse inteligente o
suficiente para desenvolver uma
ferramenta de busca mas é porque não é o
objetivo desse tipo de ferramenta ser um
repositório de informação
o mesmo se passa com o twitter
o instagram e com todas as redes sociais
isso faz com que essa garotada tenha
muito o registro do aqui e agora
eles vivem no mundo que é extremamente
complexo
pra mim não tem mais o certo ou errado é
o isso ou aquilo
antes da internet tudo que nós tínhamos
de informação ou estar organizados em
enciclopédias que aliás era chique tem
uma em casa né o pai pagava vida inteira
que ela aquela barça a conhecer pra você
ter acesso ou estava nos livros
didáticos ou era transmitido pela igreja
ou pela família
o conhecimento está organizado de uma
forma nessas bases de dados
e é a partir desse conhecimento que você
construiu a sua personalidade os seus
valores os seus princípios e aí você
seguir a sua vida e hoje não a gente tem
uma diversidade de idéias
nós temos uma quantidade de informação
que é produzida que foi produzido nos
últimos anos que é muito maior do que a
grande maioria da informação que foi
produzida no resto de toda a história da
humanidade e isso faz com que as pessoas
tenham opiniões diferentes
o fato delas estarem também o tempo todo
conectadas e tendo acesso a pessoas que
estão em qualquer lugar ea qualquer hora
faz com que também elas conheçam outras
culturas e outras pessoas e faz com que
elas tenham uma outra visão da realidade
por isso que essa garotada ela também
tem um respeito maior à diversidade
ela convive com outros valores e ela
aprende a respeitar as outras culturas
junto com tudo isso nasce uma nova
linguagem que a linguagem hipertextual
que a linguagem da internet que de um
link que remete a outro link que remete
a outro link
e se você não sabe ler por meio dessa
linguagem você se perde
então nós temos que na escola trabalhar
para que os alunos aprendam a ler por
meio dessa linguagem é uma outra lógica
traz uma outra forma de você guardar
organizar o seu raciocínio como também
tem que ensinar os alunos a produzirem
por meio dessa linguagem
e aí nós temos que trabalhar com a
produção de blogs com a produção de
wikis porque cada vez mais essa
linguagem vai fazer parte do nosso dia a
dia
então esse é um pouco do perfil dessa
garotada
quando eu olho pro contexto de economia
para o contexto de oportunidades de
empregabilidade
a gente vê que o mundo também é outro
exige outras competências é um outro
perfil de profissional que nós
precisamos
tem muita gente que nasceu foi criado e
se formou é na século passado no final
do século passado e que está tendo muita
dificuldade de conseguir seguir sua
trajetória profissional dentro desse
novo movimento porque não tem
criatividade porque não sabe pensar fora
da caixa porque não sabe se reinventar
foi criado foi formado para trabalhar
dentro de uma profissão e seguir sua
trajetória de constituição a família e
se aposentar e pronto e agora o mundo é
muito dinâmico você tem que se
reinventar o tempo inteiro e cada vez
mais a gente vai ter que se reinventar o
tempo inteiro
algumas profissões que já surgiram então
com esse movimento
são essas que estão listados aqui por
exemplo especialista em 3d
os especialistas os curadores digitais
que são pessoas que fazem pesquisa que
ajuda a fazer seleção de informação na
internet
o professor freelancer que consegue dar
uma aula à distância são algumas das
profissões que surgiram depois do
advento da internet e muitas outras
estão tendo que ser reinventadas como
por exemplo o spotify que veio mudar
toda a indústria da música
nessa tinha toda uma lógica instituída
que teve que ser mudada
nós temos aí é bem dia que mudou nem
toda parte de locação de imóveis
a netflix que mudou é toda a indústria
bibliográfica e muitas outras as pessoas
o uber né que veio mudar a realidade ea
vida dos taxistas e cada vez mais isso
vai ser presente na nossa vida
sem falar que muitos jovens querem ser
empreendedores
tem uma pesquisa que mostra que 80% dos
jovens quer empreender em dez anos e se
eles querem aprender são outras
competências que nós precisamos
trabalhar nos nossos alunos
eles precisam ter uma autogestão da sua
vida sabe acordar cedo ter
responsabilidade não tem ninguém ditando
para ele dizendo que ele tem que fazer
ele tem que saber fazer uma gestão
financeira ele tem que ter empatia para
conquistar o seu cliente
ele tem que fazer uma auto reflexão
humilde pra ele poder ver quais são os
seus limites das suas possibilidades
ele tem que saber usar as mídias sociais
e as ferramentas de e comerce pra vender
o seu produto são outras competências e
quem é professor sabe que competência
não é algo que a gente adquire do dia
para a noite
somente quando você tem a oportunidade
de exercitar muito é que você vai
desenvolver então é um trabalho que a
gente tem que fazer na escola muita
freqüência e aí o terceiro ponto que eu
gosto de olhar em um contexto de
sociedade
gosto muito desse livro do ir ao é do
rio vai honrar área
não sei se vocês já tiveram o parto na
oportunidade de ler o models que ele diz
que a gente sai de uma era do mundo sap
onde os grandes preocupações da
humanidade era com a fome com a peste
com a guerra se investir e educar
são em saúde porque precisava de pessoas
fortes para lutar em campo de batalha e
agora quando a guerra passa a ser
virtual
as pessoas deixam de ter relevância a
grande preocupação hoje ele fala que
está entrando na era do modelo é com a
felicidade com a imortalidade e com a
divindade a gente brincar diz ser deus
manipular todos os jeitos e que isso é
um grande risco tem o seu lado bom como
mostrou maurício mas também tem uma
grande preocupação que é nós sermos
controlados pela máquina que tem todo um
algoritmo capaz de fazer esse controle
mas não tem inteligência isso é uma
preocupação que nós temos que ter esse e
essa é a realidade e parece que tudo
isso não tem nada a ver com educação mas
como eu disse no começo
se nós queremos realmente ser eficientes
no trabalho que nós fazemos enquanto
professores nós temos que entender quem
é esse nosso aluno e com esse mundo que
ele vai viver para assim poder pensar
nas melhores estratégias de ensino e
aprendizagem
então se eu quero uma escola diz
repetitiva como é que ela tem que ser
ela tem que ser uma escola eu acho que a
gente não tem uma resposta ainda
nós estamos nesse movimento isso está
acontecendo está em plena ebulição é
muito difícil nesse momento a gente
chegar a uma conclusão de como tudo isso
vai acontecer mas eu já tenho algumas
diretrizes que acho que podem ajudar a
definir o nosso trabalho
primeiro que a gente não tem que ter
mais professores que estão à frente de
um processo como eu estou aqui nós temos
tempo mentores que ajudam os alunos a
fazer uma leitura crítica de uma
informação ea ler e a discernir sobre
aquela informação que ele está tendo
acesso que ajuda a desenvolver o
pensamento crítico que ajuda a trabalhar
melhor em equipe que ajuda a ele ser uma
pessoa mais justa mais humanitária
socialmente responsável
nós temos que usar os recursos
tecnológicos que estão à disposição
inclusive os que estão na mão dos alunos
um celular ele tem muitas
funcionalidades e ele pode trazer
oportunidades extremamente interessantes
de aprendizagem
nós temos que ter uma cultura pedagógica
que seja sustentada pela inovação inovar
é fazer de uma forma como nunca fiz
antes
inovar não necessariamente exige
tecnologia é repensar as metodologias é
a forma como nós trabalhamos dialogamos
com os alunos é ter uma educação que
seja um estímulo à curiosidade a olhar
crítico para a vida e autoria e que a
gente tem um currículo que esteja a
serviço do desenvolvimento de todas as
competências das competências básicas
que já estão nos pcns das competências
sócio emocionais que são extremamente
importantes e das competências
tecnológicas já que a máquina está aí e
vai caber cada vez mais fazem parte do
nosso dia a dia
pra mim a melhoria da qualidade da
educação do nosso país é uma questão
urgente e somente com um novo olhar com
muita criatividade coragem é que a gente
vai conseguir mudar a realidade que nós
temos hoje fazendo o que os nossos
alunos sejam capazes de ter e perseguir
seu sonho quem é professor aqui gostaria
que encorajasse e pensasse mais sobre
isso
muito obrigado
[Música]